>> Laura: LAST WEEK
PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGN FOR A GREAT
SET OF DRUG CASES AND IS
EXPECTED BIG PHARMA BUT THEY
ARE FIGHTING BACK.
HERE IS WHAT THE CEO OF PFIZER
SAID ON A EARNINGS CALL TODAY.
>> I AM DISAPPOINTED.
THEY POST ENORMOUS DESTRUCTION
COME AT A TIME WHEN THE INDUSTRY
NEEDS TO BE COMPLETELY FOCUSED
ON DEVELOPING A POTENTIAL
COVID-19 VACCINE OR TREATMENT,
WHICH CAN INVEST IN BOTH.
IN MANUFACTURING WITH THE
UNITED STATES.
IF FINALIZED, THE NEW EXECUTIVE
ORDERS WOULD FORCE US.
>> Laura: WELL, PFIZER, OF
COURSE EVERYONE KNOWS IS AN
AMAZING AMERICAN COMPANY, BUT
HIS GROVELING ABOUT PROFITS IS
ABSURD.
HHS AND THE PENTAGON ANNOUNCED
LAST WEEK THAT IT WOULD PAY
PFIZER INTERIM AND BIOTECH
PARTNER $1.95 BILLION TO PRODUCE
100 MILLION DOSES OF A COVID-19
VACCINE WITH THE OPTION TO BUY
AN ADDITIONAL 500 MILLION DOSES
SO YOU DO THE MATH THEY ARE.
SO THERE IS NO REASON U.S.
CITIZENS SHOULD BE PAYING MORE
THAN OTHER OECD COUNTRIES FOR
OTHER DRUGS THAT YOU KNOW PFIZER
MAKES.
THAT IS THE WHOLE POINT OF THIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER.
THE UP CHARGES ABSURD.
HERE TO RESPOND AS JOSH HAWLEY
OF MISSOURI.
SENATOR, YOU JUST HEARD THE CEO
OF PFIZER ESSENTIALLY
THREATENING TO MOVE
MANUFACTURING OVERSEAS BECAUSE
OF THESE EXECUTIVE ORDERS SPIRIT
WHAT DOES THIS TELL YOU?
>> IT TELLS YOU THAT THEY ARE
VERY INTERESTED IN THEIR PROFITS
AND THE GRAVY TRAIN THAT THEY
HAVE HAD GOING FOR A YEAR.
LISTEN, I HAVE NO SYMPATHY FOR
BIG PHARMA WHATSOEVER.
THEY ROUTINELY CHARGE AMERICANS
TWO, THREE, FOUR TIMES MORE FOR
THE SAME DRUGS THAT THEY CHARGE
PATIENTS AND SAY YOU EUROPE,
FRANCE.
I KNOW THIS IS TRUE BECAUSE WE
HAVE STUDIED THEM.
THE HOME STATE OF MISSOURI, THEY
ARE CHARGING PEOPLE THEM AS A
RATE THREE, FOUR, FIVE TIMES
MORE THAN CHARGING FOLKS IN
FRANCE, GERMANY AND CANADA AND
I’M GLAD THE PRESIDENT IS
STANDING UP TO THEM.
>> Laura: AND AGAIN, I THINK
THE MONEY THAT IS GIVEN BY THE
DRUG COMPANIES TO BOTH POLITICAL
PARTIES, IT IS ASTRONOMICAL.
THEY ARE AMONG THE BIGGEST
DONORS TO POLITICS IN THE
UNITED STATES, AND THAT IS FINE.
THAT IS WHAT THEY DO, BUT LET’S
NOT ALL THINK THIS IS JUST
CHARITABLE ENDEAVORS.
THIS IS A BUSINESS, A COMPANY
BUT THEY HAVE GOTTEN A FREE
RIDE.
I WANT TO ASK YOU, SENATOR ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT’S DECISION, THE
ADMINISTRATION’S DECISION TO
GIVE KODAK A BOOST IN ORDER TO
KEEP SOME MEDICAL MANUFACTURING
IN THE UNITED STATES.
THERE ARE A LOT OF CONSERVATIVES
OUT THERE, FREE MARKETEERS WHO
WOULD SAY, WE ARE PLAYING
FAVORITES.
TO THAT YOU SAY?
>> WELL, I WOULD SAY LISTEN, IT
IS IMPORTANT WE MANUFACTURE AS
MANY FROM SURGICAL PRODUCTS THAT
WE CAN IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE FACT THAT WE MANUFACTURE SO
FEW DRUGS IN THE LONGER
PARTICULARLY DRUGS LIKE INSULIN,
WE MANUFACTURED 0% IN THIS
COUNTRY.
MAJOR PHARMACEUTICAL PRODUCTS.
WE HAVE FOUND BECAUSE OF THE
COVID-19 CRISIS, WE ARE DEEPLY
DEPENDENT ON FOREIGN SUPPLY
CHAIN SPIRIT SO I THINK IT IS
INCUMBENT TO LOOK AT ALL THE
OPTIONS FOR BRINGING THOSE SUPPL
CHAINS BACK, FORGETTING
MEDICAL PRODUCTION AND TO THIS
COUNTRY.
TO GO BACK TO BIG PHARMA, YOU
KNOW, AGAIN I DON’T HAVE ANY
SYMPATHIES FOR THESE GUYS, BIG
PHARMA, BIG GOVERNMENT ALLIANCE
HAS BEEN GREAT FOR BIG PHARMA.
THEY HAVE MADE A KILLING THESE
LAST FEW YEARS AND REALLY FOR
DECADES.
IT’S TIME THEY START PUTTING
PATIENTS FIRST.
>> Laura: SENATOR, A COUPLE OF
WEEKS BACK SPEAKING OF BIDEN, HE
SAID WE SHOULD RE-EXAMINE
TRUMP’S TARIFFS ON CHINA AND OF
COURSE THAT IS WHY CHINA CAME TO
THE BARGAINING TABLE IN THESE
TRADE DEALS.
BUT TODAY, BIDEN CAME OUT AND
PRETENDED THAT HE WAS GOING TO
BE THE ONE AFTER FOUR DECADES IN
WASHINGTON TO PUT AMERICA FIRST.
WATCH.
>> USING FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN APPROPRIATED
TO FOCUS THEM ON BUILDING THINGS
THAT MAKE US INCREASE OUR
INDEPENDENCE.
SO WE DON’T HAVE TO RELY ON
ANYONE ELSE FOR WEATHER CYBER
SECURITY, CYBER INFORMATION, WE
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO IT AT
HOME.
DO THEM AT HOME.
>> Laura: OKAY, SENATOR, IS IT
MY MISTAKE OR NOT, MY
REMEMBERING THIS INCORRECTLY,
WHAT WASN’T HE VICE PRESIDENT
AND ADMINISTRATION FOR EIGHT
YEARS?
I MUST HAVE MISSED ALL THAT WORK
ON THESE ISSUES OF BRINGING
MANUFACTURING BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES.
>> THE PROBLEM WITH JOE BIDEN IS
HE IS A CLASSIC CHINA APPEASER.
AND HE HAS BEEN HIS WHOLE
POLITICAL CAREER.
HE CERTAINLY WAS AS
VICE PRESIDENT.
I MEAN, HECK, EVEN EARLIER THIS
YEAR HE WAS QUESTIONING WHETHER
CHINA WAS A GEOSTRATEGIC THREAT.
THAT TURNED OUT TO BE A LITTLE
BIT OF A PROBLEM FOR HIM AS WE
HAVE SEEN WITH COVID-19, WHICH
IS WHY HE DOESN’T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE PAST STATEMENTS.
THIS GUY HAS NEVER STOOD UP TO
CHINA AND IN FACT ALL TOO EAGER
TO ROLL OUT THE RED CARPET TO
CHINA AND GIVE THEM WHATEVER
THEY WANT, SELL OUT OUR
JOBS, WORKERS.
THAT IS THE PROBLEM.
WE ARE STILL CLEANING UP FROM
HIS MESS OF YEARS AGO.
WHY WOULD WE GO BACK TO THOSE
FAILED POLICIES?
WE DON’T NEED MORE APPEASEMENT.
WE NEED TO GET TOUGH ON CHINA.
THIS PRESENT AND STARTED TO DO
IT AND WE NEED MORE OF THAT.
>> Laura: I WOULD NOT LET YOU
GET AWAY WITHOUT LIKE YOU SAID
THIS PAST WEEKEND WHERE YOU
SAID, QUITE CANDIDLY, YOU WOULD
NOT SUPPORT HIM A SUPREME COURT
NOMINEE UNLESS HE OR SHE HAD PUB
NOMINATION THAT ROE VS. WADE WAS
WRONGLY DECIDED.
NOW, IS THAT A LITMUS TEST THAT
EVEN SOME REPUBLICANS WILL BACK
AWAY FROM?
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE?
>> YOU KNOW, YOU CAN CALL IT
WHATEVER YOU WANT, LAURA MIGHT
CALL IT ASK BASIC QUESTIONS
ABOUT JUDICIAL PHILOSOPHY.
I ALSO CALL IT THE END OF THE
TRUST BEST APPROACH.
FOR YEARS CONSERVATIVES
ESPECIALLY RELIGIOUS
CONSERVATIVES, LET’S BE HONEST
TOLD BY THE D.C. ESTABLISHMENT
JUST TRUST US, DON’T ASK TOO
MANY QUESTIONS.
CERTAINLY DON’T ASK ABOUT
ROE VS. WADE BUT TRUST US.
I’M THROUGH WITH THAT.
I WANT TO KNOW BECAUSE
ROE VS. WADE IS CENTRAL,
ROE VS. WADE IS JUDICIAL
IMPERIALISM.
AND IF YOU THINK IT WAS RIGHTLY
DECIDED, HE OR SHE IS PEERLESS
AND GNOMIC FEARLESS AND I WILL
NOT VOTE FOR THEM.
>> Laura: WE HAVE TO HAVE
MURKOWSKI TO SIGN ONTO A
JUDICIAL SUPREME COURT PICK.
BUT I AGREE YOU LOOK AT ROBERT’S
RECORD AND COURSE SEARCH ON SOME
ISSUES AND YOU WONDER WHAT THE